And so not only do you need the value
structure so that you don't just
deteriorate and die.
You need the value structure so that
when the flood comes in your life as it
certainly will,
that you have built a vessel that will
sustain you through the catastrophe and
that's not this pursuit of happiness.
It's not even the pursuit of security.
It's none of that.
It's the orientation that you've managed
to produce in your own life towards a
higher good that's so high that it's
worth bearing the burden of being to
produce.
You implement that in the world.
You produce a hierarchy.
Now you might say,
well,
and then you have the problem of
hierarchy in the problem of hierarchy is
a very few people are going to be very
good at whatever that hierarchy does and
then you have the second problem with
hierarchy,
which is the problem I just laid out
when I asked you about your spectacular
levels of attainment and found out that
they were very,
it was very unlikely.
I'm not saying that you haven't detained
worthwhile things.
That's not my point.
My point is,
is that very high levels of attainment
are extraordinarily rare.
And that's an inevitability.
As soon as you decide that something's
worth doing to inevitabilities,
people stack up at the top minority of
people stack up at the top and take most
of the proceeds,
whatever they happen to be or deserve
them or earn them,
whatever.
However,
I don't care how you conceptualize it
and almost everybody else stacks up at
the bottom.
And so the problem with hierarchies is
that even though they're necessary,
they tend to produce a situation where
most people stack up at the bottom.
And so that's the next thing that we
have to contend with.
You can't get rid of the hierarchies
because if you get rid of the
hierarchies,
there's no value structure.
And if there's no value structure,
not only do you deteriorate and die,
you want to deteriorate and die,
and that's not a good solution.
But if you do generate a hierarchy,
then you have the problem of the
hierarchy.
And the problem is the hierarchy is that
it will dispossess most people now to
the degree that the postmodernists have
something to say,
that's what they say is hierarchies.
Dispossess okay.
And then we can look at that clearly and
carefully.
And we can say that doesn't mean a,
that hierarchies themselves are corrupt
or that we can dispense with them.
But it also doesn't mean that we have no
moral obligation to the dispossessed.
And we say,
well,
how do we deal with that politically,
conceptually.
And the way we deal with that,
at least in part,
is to produce a political spectrum that
ranges from left to right that deals
with hierarchy and the problems that
hierarchies because so one of the things
that you can reliably assume about
someone who's on the right is that they
will be patriotically in favor of the
current hierarchy or even more
abstractly,
they're in favor.
The idea of hierarchy itself.
And you say,
well,
more power to the people on the right
because you need hierarchies.
So they should support them.
But then you have to take the people on
the left who say,
yeah,
but what about the people who are
dispossessed by the hierarchy?
And what you have to say to them is,
yeah,
we actually have to do something about
that.
And you think,
well,
how did we do something about that?
And the answer is we don't actually know
because there's no permanent solution to
the problem of dispossession by the
hierarchy.
We don't know how to fix it.
You say,
well,
we could flatten the hierarchies.
It's like not without disrupting the
value structure.
That's a price you don't want to pay.
Well,
we could take from the top and put it at
the bottom.
It's like,
yes,
hypothetically we could.
But it turns out that when you try that
in practice,
it's very,
very easy to rapidly go too far.
And then what you end up with not is
less dispossessed.
You end up with no one who has anything.
And that's not a good solution to the
problem of scarcity,
right?
To make everyone equally dead or equally
starving,
which is essentially what the communists
states did across the entirety of the
20th century is not the proper way to
address the problem of hierarchy.
Now it has to be addressed even if
you're on the right because here's one
thing that happens.
Hierarchies tend to Ossify,
you know,
because what happens is that the people
at the top,
maybe they got there by merit,
but it's easy for them to Gerrymander
the system so they can stay there
without merit.
Or perhaps their children can stay there
without merit or they can,
or the hierarchy becomes corrupt so that
people who only use tyranny and power
can climate,
and so you don't have a hierarchy of
competence and value anymore.
You have a hierarchy of brute power,
which looks like a tyranny,
and so there's all sorts of ways that
hierarchies can deteriorate and we have
to be awake to ensure that that doesn't
occur.
Also,
if the hierarchy gets so steep that
everybody stacks up at zero and no one
can climb it,
which is basically the definition of a
malfunctioning tyranny than all the
people at the bottom rightly think,
well,
why don't we just destroyed the game
because we're already at zero?
So what the hell do we have to lose?
And so one of the things that you want
to do if you're a sensible conservative,
is make sure that the hierarchy
maintains its rooting in competence,
that it's transparent and that it's
climate bowl.
Because otherwise it will also Phi and
steepen and then it will destroy itself.
And if you're a conservative and you
value stability and the hierarchy,
then you don't want to set up a
situation where the most likely outcome
is that the hierarchy destroys itself.
So,
so we can be intelligent about this.
We could say,
look,
don't be thinking can get rid of
hierarchies they've been around.
This is why I wrote chapter one I talked
about lobsters.
The reason I talked about them is
because not only is the hierarchical
structure itself as a permanent feature
of existence,
at least a third of a billion years old,
which by the way means that you cannot
attribute it to capitalism,
the free market or the corrupt
patriarchal west,
unless you're willing to make the case
that all three of those elements
contributed to the existence of
dominance hierarchies among crustaceans,
which seems highly unlikely.
So,
and,
and this is actually something that's,
that you can think about it as an idea
that's actually directed towards the
productive left.
If you want to help the dispossessed,
don't blame the existence of hierarchies
on capitalism because it's wrong.
It's wrong that the problem is way
deeper than that.
And here's something else that's very
interesting about capitalism.
Couple of things you might consider,
you know,
we have become spectacularly wealthy
since 1895 right?
First in the West Icelands at classic
example.
I mean you guys are so much more wealthy
than you were a hundred years ago that
it's absolutely impossible to believe.
And so that's first happened in the west
to exponential economic growth starting
in about 1895 there's a long tail.
I mean,
people were improving before that,
but it really kicked in around 1895 and
first happened in the west and now it's
happening everywhere in the world.
I don't know if you know this,
but you know,
um,
the UN set a goal in 2000 to have the
level of absolute poverty in the world
by 2015 which is the fastest rate of
economic growth ever recorded.
We attained it in 2012,
three years ahead of the most optimistic
projections.
Right?
And so people are being lifted out of
poverty at a rate that has never been
seen in the history of the world hooked
to the power grids provided with cell
phones provided with free,
with access to fresh water provided with
access to medications that decrease
child mortality.
Like if you look at the statistics,
there are so many things getting better
so fast you cannot even believe it.
And that's,
and here's that's a consequences as far
as,
as far as the data indicate of the
operation of the free market system,
which does produce inequality.
That's the thing.
But as far as I can tell,
the only system that has ever produced
wealth and as law or has every system
produces inequality,
but the only system we know of that
produces,
produces wealth and inequality is the
free market.
So here's a question for everyone left
and right.
How many units of inequality will you
tolerate to produce one unit of wealth?
And if the answer is zero,
then you've gone too far.
You're outside the appropriate political
debate.
That's the wrong answer.
And if you try to impose all there will
be as mayhem because the price we pay
for wealth is inequality.
Now that doesn't mean that you can let
inequality run to its ultimate extreme
because then you run into the other
problem,
which is the monopoly problem.
You've all played monopoly.
I presume what happens in every monopoly
game,
if you lay it out,
everyone's stacks out at zero,
zero except one person.
Now if you play it 50 times,
you'll find that it's hardly ever the
same person because it's basically a
game of chance and there's a fair bit of
chance,
by the way,
operating in the distribution of money
in the world.
It's not all chance,
but there's a fair bit of chance.
But the logical conclusion to a
hierarchy that can play itself out
totally is that one person has
everything and everyone else has
nothing.
Obviously that's not a useful outcome.
So,
so you know,
the way there are ways that we fix that
in our society,
we have progressive tax policies and you
can argue about their utility,
but that's one way of rectifying it
potentially.
Another way of rectifying is that we
don't have one game right?
In a pluralistic society,
we have many,
many games that people can play.
And so if you can't be a successful
lawyer,
then maybe you could be a successful
plumber.
And if you can't be a successful
plumber,
maybe you can run this small restaurant
or you know,
there's a diversity of games.
And so that's a good way of,
of allowing,
of,
of increasing the robustness of the
system so that you don't get hierarchies
that are so steep that they collapse in
and,
um,
in an,
in upon themselves.
And so those are sophisticated
approaches and perhaps your other
approach is to,
but it's an intractable problem.
It says in the New Testament,
it's one of the things you'd swear would
be edited out because it's such a harsh
statement.
The poor will be with us always.
Well,
what's that in reference to?
It's also in reference to the Matthew
principle,
which is another new testament statement
and happens to be an economic axiom to
those who have everything more will be
given from those who have nothing.
Everything will be taken.
That's the structure of the world and
you can't lay it at the feet of the
West.
It's the structure of the world now.
That means we have to contend with it.
And it's not an easy thing to contend
with.
And part of the reason that we have a
continual political dialogue and that we
need to have a continual political
dialogue,
is to make sure that our hierarchies
exist and remain intact,
but don't become so steep and corrupt
that they destroy themselves.
And you need a left and a right for
that.
And if and,
but that means the left half has to
admit that hierarchies are not only
necessary but valuable.
And the right has to admit that despite
their necessity in value,
they tend to stack people up at the
bottom.
And that actually constitutes a
continual problem.